Kathy is with us in Boston hi Kathy
welcome to Dave Ramsey show hey how are
you better than I deserve what's up I'm
lucky to get a hold of you today I had
scary scary news your phone is breaking
up your phone all right I'm sorry can
you hear me now yes I can okay I'm near
a window now but I got the front my
local paper today and there's a scary
headline saying my financial advisor has
been accused of scamming clients more
than 1 million dollars how much have you
got with them more than 1 million
dollars you do we do
what's it invested in its invested in
mutual funds you have statements that
show it I get statements from a company
called pursing every month does it show
the money in the investments it does it
does it is about 14 pages that come
every month with the investments listed
okay but Pershing's not the end that
that must be the broker that the advisor
was with but not the actual mutual funds
right right person is the broker I
believe do you have the actual mutual
funds the statements from the actual
mutual funds or do you know what funds
you're actually in and what your account
number is with the mutual fund not with
the mutual funds no just four person I
know but I'm saying you don't know the
name of the mutual fund that Pershing
has put you in I'm sure it's on the
statements correct should be so well one
thing you can do is immediately call the
SEC the Securities and Exchange
Commission who's probably after this guy
and you know tell them you're freaking
out and what can they tell you okay
about the investigation and what you
should do is your next step that's
that's one thing you would do second
thing I would do is I would
pick up my statements and say alright
I'm supposed to have money in a BC
mutual fund and my account number is
so-and-so call that mutual fund and go
this is Kathy so-and-so you know I'm
supposed to have X number of dollars in
this mutual fund and I need to verify
that there's actually money in that fund
in my name okay okay and he is I'm not
familiar with the name pursing so it is
that a larger firm or that he's supposed
to be a local branch of or is that the
name of his firm well he's actually a
local branch of United planners okay
cold I looked up on I looked on up on
the internet and they're in Arizona okay
call them to okay and start you know
tell them what's going on that you need
to know how to take your statements
apart and here's my hope okay that your
money actually got into those mutual
funds if it actually got into those
mutual funds you're probably safe okay
but if he's if he's diverting it with as
a complete crook a complete fraud of a
bank robber basically if he's diverting
the embezzling the money and then
printing off falsified statements then
you may have a real problem that's
possible okay so on the SEC the
Securities and Exchange Commission is
your ruling body on this get in touch
with them immediately in your area
they'll have a location or a agent
assigned to the Boston area that you can
get some help from and and then call
United planners whoever that is that
they're a part of that he's somehow a
part of get some information from them
number two number three try to reach the
actual mutual fund company and so mutual
funds are there called families of funds
which is the brand name okay and so an
example would be fidelity is a brand
name and Campbell's is a brand name now
Campbell's has chicken suit
and they have vegetable soup fidelity
has you know a whole bunch of different
mutual funds so fidelity is not what
you're looking for you're looking for
the actual fund fidelity Magellan would
be an actual fund right if it's American
funds an actual fund is an investment
company of America ICA and American
funds and so it's not just American
funds you need to get a hold of its ICA
with your account number to try to
figure out if you've got money in that
account literally and if you do then
your that's going to give you a lot of
rest and you're gonna get some sleep in
addition to that the vice president of
our smart Buster program that this guy's
not a smart investor I'm sure okay
he isn't because I tried to find one
when we was getting ready to roll over
this I know this 401 K and there wasn't
one in our area okay all right well the
guy that is the vice president of our
that runs that whole program for us
inside of our company here is brilliant
on this kind of a thing and so even
though we've got nothing to do with it
just to help you I'm going to put you on
hold and Kelly is going to connect you
to one of our vice presidents and he'll
be able to give you some also some
better advice maybe even than I have on
getting in here and getting you some
peace that your money has not just been
flushed down the toilet somewhere so
what a scary horrible thing yeah you
roll a million dollars into something
you look up the guy you're working with
on the front page as being the next
Bernie Madoff oh my gosh what a horrible
deal yeah that take your breath away
right there cause your pulse rate to
change
ouch so hold on and Kelly will pick up
Cathy and will try to help you and get
you some help around this even though as
you and I said it's not not one of our
guys by any stretch of the imagination
but but but I hate it when one of these
guys does this because it discredits and
makes everybody scared about doing
investing then and then they shouldn't
be because 99.9% of people in the
business or wonderful people